and he speaking about
very
the I think we're going to need to do a
little bit better than that as
I still think we have more
energy come on these are the victors You
Are The Champions you are the
victors of the great civil rights
movement let's do this one more timeall
God I don't know if any of you are
following the
news I try to follow the news and the
language and the Dutch language all I
see is a picture of
myself and someone speaking in a way I
don't understand but I don't think
they're saying very good
things I asked my
friend to translate some of those things
and they told me they are saying such
and such in fact I saw a
video of them coming to this very
Conference Center the
media and coming to people who have no
dog in the fight have nothing to do with
it and trying to harass them asking them
in fact they even went to
non-muslims and asked them about
Muhammad hijab white people in the
streets
and to be
fair from what I understand my friends
translated it that they said we don't
know anything about him we don't so they
even weren't buying the propaganda but
what I want to do to start off
today is since the media wants to harass
the people in this conference
Hall and they don't want to come to me I
was open I said come I'll be in a room
spending all this time not one of them
came maybe some of them
saw what happened to Pierce
[Applause]
Morgan may maybe some other one saw what
happened to Rabbi shoi
[Applause]
maybe they saw what happened to
dtz maybe they even saw what happened to
David
wood but since I'm a
man who doesn't mind being
questioned I give this time now on stage
I know the media is here anybody who
wants to ask me a question can come on
this stage right now and ask me whatever
you want I will give you 60 seconds to
come
[Applause]
up where is
Faber where is Wilders
where are those
people what is the point of talking
about freedom of speech when you are
freedom of speech
[Applause]
cowards what is the point of talking
about freedom of
expression when you only care about some
freedom of expression and not other
let me tell you something yesterday I
asked a question and it was a poignant
and pertinent question and the question
was do you think that they would do this
with a Jewish person that they would ban
entry to not just Holland but 26 shenen
European countries to a rabbi for having
illiberal traditionalist views what was
the answer yes or
no let me hear that again yes or no no
one more time yes or
no I want you to do it in Dutch this
time yes or
no yeah you know that one don't
you it's true they wouldn't because if
they would they would have when those
Israelis came for the football match if
you remember you remember
this and they are known the T aiv makab
or whatever they were called I think
they lost the match I think they lost
the match as well they are known for
their anti-arab and racist
sentiments yet no Minister dead to come
and say that coming them coming into
this country would be a breach of the
peace and it was a breach of the
peace it was a breach of the
peace I wonder now if the Ministers of
this country are going to ban them next
time I guarantee you they will not ban
them next time because they will say it
is
anti-Semitism this is what they
say and that is why the point must be
made over and over
again that
you the pvv and your
Associates the so-called Freedom Party
and your
Associates and those like you like the
ADL in Germany and the far right all
over have to make a decision and that
decision is whether you want to be true
to what you
say which is a liberal democracy or the
whether you want to be
fascists Nazis
fascists whether you want to go in the
direction of JS Mill or whether you want
to go in the direction of Carl Schmidt
or even Adolf Hitler
we saw Elon Musk do the Hitler
salute and one of his associates
reaching out to me only two weeks before
I came or 3 weeks before I came here
threatening
me that if I don't stop talking about
this or
that they said if they don't stop
speaking if you don't stop speaking you
will be put in prison this is what he
said to
me we will put you in
prison and he said he heard this from
the mouth of Elon Musk
directly two 3 weeks
later I was meant to come here they
banned me from this country and 26 other
countries I don't know whether or not
this is a coincidence what do you think
is it coincidence yes or no no
you see if I had that same opinion maybe
they'd take me to court but that's your
opinion that's
fine I think there's a
project at play a global
project that aims to remove and expunge
and
eliminate Islam and Muslims especially
from
Europe and we the Muslims must have a
response and just to be clear because I
know people are watching and listening
our response is not a violent response
it is
not and how dare you talk about
violence when you are the
ones who have been supporting and aiding
the greatest genocide in the last 50 to
100 years in the Palestinian genocide
how dare you speak to
[Music]
us how dare you talk to
us about the prophet Muhammad sallallah
alaihi
wasam about our
prophet and about
tolerance and about
acceptance and about plurality and
pluralism when I can guarantee you the
prophet Muhammad
1,400 years ago exhibited more
tolerance more freedom of
religion then your pvv party and all of
your parties and every single one of
your parties in Europe put
[Music]
together and the evidence of that is
that the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam in his Immaculate
leadership as 1,400 years
ago made a
Constitution which gave Jewish people
which gave Christian people which gave
non-muslim people full rights of
protection and that the Quran
says that there is no compulsion in
religion that truth has been made clear
from falsehood
this is what the Quran says and in
fact and
those
M
they allow Jews and Christians to have
their own
courts to rule by their own laws on
matters to do with their own
issues this is a freedom that the West
hasn't even realized with the Muslim
populations until
today they don't allow it for
us so Don't lecture us about freedom of
expression freedom of religion and
tolerance with
religion the rightwing parties of this
country they attack the prophet Muhammad
explicitly people like gar
Wilders who wants to see a ban of the
Quran
who has put that on record and who is so
extreme that other members of parliament
couldn't even make him to a prime
minister despite his party having a
majority in the senate in the House of
Representatives is that right or
not say it in Dutch yes or
no yes or
no get
Wilders and people like him like that
woman
Fab his
dog and if there weren't children in
this room I'd use a more stringent
term that when he says to her
jump the only thing she can say to him
is how
high that they have the audacity to talk
to us about these matters with that kind
of track record let me ask you a
question do you think the pvv or any
other politician in Holland would even
be given a seat in the senate or the
House of Representatives if they said we
should ban the
talud yes or
no they talk to us and they put this on
the media
about
pedophilia and they accused the holy
prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam of such a
thing they say that we are glorifying
such a
thing I think they have gotten us
confused with the rabbis of the townwood
who said that Rebecca was 3 years old
when she married Isaac
according to Genesis according to the
Old
Testament Islam is the only religion of
the three abrahamic religions which has
an
explicit condemnation of
pedophilia if you want to ban a religion
which has interpretations for
Millennia of a pedophilic nature then
you have no further to look than the
Jewish sources the talmud the midrashim
and all those things with it I challenge
you to speak about those
sources I challenge everybody on the
right to show that they are not Shackled
by the expectations and the Commandments
of the zionists by
criticizing
Judaism they will never do it
Volare said and he was meant to be one
of the great liberal
thinkers that I don't I detest what you
say he said but I will fight to the
death your right to say it this is the
emblematic lotion of freedom of
expression and some other things are
attributed to him for example the
saying that if you want to know who's in
charge of
you look at who you cannot
criticize so we ask who is it that the
Dutch government and all the politicians
cannot
criticize when was the last time you
heard them criticize the
zionists have you heard them criticized
them
no I was
online and I saw that they were
attacking the holy prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and they were saying about him
that he killed
600 Jews of
banua and that that's an
indication that he is
anti-Semitic and
therefore we should be warned against
the religion of
Islam i f find it
incredulous that the very criticisms
they have of
Islam are not just confessions of their
own position but proofs of the opposite
of what they are trying to
say because in
fact the incident with
banua was exactly the way things should
have been since the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was am did not kill a single
innocent did not kill a single woman did
not kill a single
child and he forbade us from doing
that and in fact there was due process
and a judicial
process spearheaded by a person who the
Jewish
[Music]
combatants had chosen inad mu
such that even Karen Armstrong herself
in her book a short introduction to
Islam says that this was nothing to do
with the fact that they were
Jewish and I find it more
incredulous that they are talking about
600 combatant Jews that were killed
1,400 years ago and they have forgotten
about 50,000 killed Palestinians that
were just killed two months
ago how seriously do you want us to take
you when you haven't condemned women and
children being killed in Cold Blood
incinerated
blasted
burnt
destroyed you don't care about them yet
you want us to care about 600 combatants
from 1,400 years
ago and you want us to take you
seriously the banua
incident and others like it like
fat were all actual examples of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
diplomatic judgments his Mercy his J
Justice if only you had dealt with us
the way the prophet dealt with his
enemies if only the Israelis had dealt
with the
Palestinians the way the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
dealt with the
Jews don't ever speak to us about how we
should behave when you have the most
horrible track record of all of
history and now you are crying about
immigration you are saying saying there
are too many Moroccans in this
country too many people from Surinam and
Morocco and this country and that
country and these African
countries why don't they go back home
they
say my question to those who say that
like G Wilders and others is if that's
the principle you operate on when was
the last time you went to South Africa
and told the African canas there the
white South Africans to leave and go
back to
Holland have you ever heard G Wilders
tell the white South Africans to leave
and go back to Holland no yes or no no
in fact in
2018 geralt Wilders said the opposite he
said the white South Africans should
come here to Holland and they they have
freedom of
Asylum and they've always been
supportive
of
them they don't say they don't have a
right to citizenship in South Africa
they would never say such a thing which
shows you the matter is not about
immigration it's about
race it's about race and
[Music]
religion and that's why I say to The
Honorable Dutch people the good Dutch
people who have overachieved in this
country a country
which has excellent engineering progress
everywhere I go I see fantastic
engineering and so on and so forth I say
to them don't fall for
it you have a good reputation don't fall
for
this we the
Muslims we want to have a good
relationship with the rest of the people
dominant populations in Europe yes or No
Yes or No Yes or No Yes do we we want to
harm our brothers and sisters people who
are non-muslim here in Holland no no we
don't we want to be lawful members of
society but it's a two-way
street if you're going to be racist to
us and then expect us to conform that's
a recipe for
disaster you can't remove our
citizenships
just know that for you to be able to
remove our citizenships you need to
change your
constitutions and become
fascist so since you can't remove our
citizenships you have to learn to get
along with us because we are ready to
get along with you
[Applause]
inshallah I will call it a day you guys
have been beautiful and honorable to me
after the ban and the historical moment
I would like to say from the bottom of
my heart that I do love you
all you going to say it
back again